the American Film Institute was a great
Learning Place um a great man who's
partly responsible for me being in this
industry he named Tony valani and he was
the head of the American film at the
time and Tony was a noons person um at
that time was a cutting
process you paid your money and you were
not guaranteed to finish the two years
because every quarter in the
basement um of the school there was a
sheet of paper if your name was not on
it you were
dismissed and they were preparing you
for the reality of this industry of the
rejection and how no matter how good you
thought you were you to keep kicking
your game up and so what it gave me is
no matter what anybody else says about
my work and I see it in the
theater I know it could be better and
I'm always thinking about man I wish I
have one more day or one more take with
that actor or whatever it is I could
have done it
better um so they gave you a realistic
understanding of the industry and
prepared you for it pretty
well
um I
think what every school does it sends
you out there with hopes and
dreams it tells you that it's not going
to be
easy but they really don't tell you how
hard it's really going to
be because I think they don't want to
discourage you from
because it's
like it's a
beast I mean not only for black people
anybody I
mean it's like why are we doing it you
you wonder sometimes you I
mean well you know I I could retire I
mean I could just
live but you know there's something that
um I had a dinner at my house this was
like a a year ago and uh like nine
people were there and the discussion was
about in your lifetime out of all of the
people you've ever known what percentage
of them ended up doing what they wanted
to do with their
lives percentage percentage which
three
3% so when I look at my good
fortune all I continue to go through and
have been through but I am still doing
at my age what I want to do with my life
and I wake up every day and I want to do
more I do never want to retire no matter
what the pain has been I feel like been
blessed because most of my friends that
I grew up with are
dead or if they're not dead they retired
from jobs they hated that they did for
35 years or more and they retire and
they sit on the porch and go on cruises
and stuff which is okay okay they never
enjoy one day of
work not one
day there's
something why do you think most people
choose that because I think you know
most people know deep down inside what
they really want to
do is it it just that it's too difficult
it
well why do most people make that choice
I think security
there's some security in
having you know two kids and the house
and the
car um working at a job that gives you
insurance for your family
vacations um retirement
guaranteed um it there's a certain
security about having
that some people weigh
happiness against
security for 90% of people security
always wins particularly if you have
kids because once you have a
child I mean it's your life is secondary
to the needs of what you've created in
this
world but um there's another side to it
in
that if you wake up every morning and uh
you don't have
security but you love waking up
up you love going to work you love the
fight no matter how painful it is you
you
will okay Goliath my Stone's not that
big but I see your damn eye
man I see right here man I'm not saying
today but you see this little I'm I'm
I'm twirling I'm twirling the stone you
know it's taking me longer than I
thought you're going down
Joe after spending what 1.3 million on
legal fees for crude in 2011 you
expressed concerns about being able to
make documentaries in the future
especially about legal cases yeah so
what changed and how were you able to
make Whitey yeah um well as you know the
crude lawsuit was very draining
emotionally financially psychologically
um and actually that was in 2010 and
there was one day I was sitting at my
kitchen table with my wife writing some
very big checks to lots of lawyers and
you know and I said if something doesn't
change you know we could lose
everything um luckily things did change
and you know I I emerged from crude from
that lawsuit you know okay um but I had
become disillusioned about whether
documentaries can really affect change
and if this is the price you have to pay
maybe I need to rethink my career um but
then that year was bookended beautifully
in August of 2011 a year exactly a year
later from that day where I was writing
all these big checks uh it was announced
that the West Memphis 3 were getting out
of prison and of course the films you
know the paradise LW Series played a big
role in that because it was kind of
those films you know while I don't want
to take full credit or even anything
close to that because a lot of very
unique circumstances came together and
tens of thousands of people you know
very generously agitated for the you
know the release of the West Memphis 3
and notable celebrities came in and you
know a unique set of circumstances came
together to release the West Memphis 3
or or to put pressure on the authorities
um but the films were the Catalyst for
that and so after having had a horrible
year getting clobbered in my lawsuit
against
Chevron um I had you know the opposite
experience where I saw the power of
documentaries that you know films can
affect positive social change that they
had a deep impact on uh on the west
Memphis 3 case and thankfully that
renewed my spirit and uh I got out of my
doldrums and I you know carried on and
so the next big project that came along
was uh the Whitey Bulger film uh and you
know uh luckily CNN films encouraged me
to make that film and so I did not have
to struggle for financing on that one
CNN you know paid for it um so it wasn't
really so much about the money it was
more about the emotional fortitude it
requires to make these kinds of films to
enter into these kinds of Worlds the
battles you have to
undertake to you know get your story out
there and after the crude experience and
you know I I had I had a little bit of
the life drained out of me but
thankfully with the release of the West
Memphis 3 I'm back in business and and
made and decided to and decided to make
the Whitey Bulger
film for many many years I had told
myself look if things don't work out I
will raise money and I will make an
independent film myself because so much
of of this business if you're a director
primarily less as a writer because as a
writer you just write something and if
it's really good people will see that if
they read it uh and so the trick is just
getting them to read your script but as
a director you have to direct something
to prove what you can do and often
shorts are just you know ignored uh by
the industry to a certain extent um
people for some reason and it doesn't
make a lot of sense producers see a
wellone short and they'll in their head
they'll go oh yeah but that's just a
short where's your feature and you know
most people don't have features because
they're very expensive to make and if
they're not very expensive they tend to
look like crap um so in the back of my
head I always had this idea that if I
didn't break in eventually and I was
never sure what eventually meant that I
would raise money and make an
independent
film and um I should have probably done
that in my late 20s or when I hit 30 but
it took another five or six years before
I finally decided that none of these
almost happened
jobs had ever actually happened and so I
should just buckle down and do this uh
and so that's what happened is um myself
and a partner we put together a business
plan we raised
$150,000 um and we made a film and it
was that film that uh finally got David
L one of the partners at the Asylum to
take me seriously even though I'd known
him for 10 years um I'd just been a
friend I'd just been that oh yeah that
guy um who wanted to make movies but
never had so now I had this thing that I
could put in front of him and say here
look this is entertaining people watch
this and they enjoy
it and he couldn't deny that um and so
you know he put me in touch with his
director of development and they started
including me when they were looking for
new ideas and eventually we uh we moved
on to making a film
together so to follow up on what you
just said about you know Hollywood films
just crushing so many independent movies
that being said you're now working on
your fifth feature so you're able to
move through that when a lot of people
that have been in La for many many
years don't even come close to that and
working with some of the names you've
worked with how is that
possible well I don't think I'm
more gifted or smarter than anyone else
I just want to do it bad enough and this
goes back to what I was saying before I
create my own opportunities I'm not
going to wait for someone to say oh now
we're going to let you make this movie I
figure out a way to do it whether and
I've always said this whenever I go into
a movie especially movie like Steel City
I said I'm going to make this for 30,000
or 300,000 I'm going to make this movie
and I think once you do that and you
create the sense of urgency and you
you're moving forward people more people
start to hop on um but I'm no smarter
than it or more I think there's a lot of
passionate people out here who
passionate about acting or passionate
and um who want to do this and they're
convinced this is their life that's
great but if you're really convinced
this is your life then you have to make
it your life make it a career and I have
made this I made the promise to myself
that I would never give up I would
continue doing it despite whatever
setbacks hey if I've got go get another
day job you know cleaning carpet or
working in a warehouse I'll do that
that's fine but I'm never going to
abandon what I feel such an essential
part of who I am as a person what I can
offer what I you know I think given a
bigger scale G given a bigger canvas
whether it's Hollywood and I think
eventually I'm going to get there um
I'll be able to do something that's
going to really affect you know have may
say something to you know to reach a
wide
audience but I don't I'm not entitled
that's why I keep doing these small
movies and figuring it out because you
know I really feel that one day I'll be
in a position to reach a wide audience
and when that
happens when they say where did this guy
come from they'll say oh he's been doing
all this stuff he's been working he's
been developing his craft to get here
you know
and that's what I'm doing and I need
help and I need the support of people
and I need Crews and great actors and
everyone to to to come to the thing but
I also am sensitive and I think a lot of
people don't realize this too who come
out here they have to get something out
of it too this isn't the Brian Jun party
and this isn't the whomever the bill
Jones party or whatever they got to get
something out of it too whether you
write you do your due diligence and you
write a great script that people that
actors are really going to like and you
raise money to pay your crew or if you
don't have money to pay your crew you
hire people who are willing to work for
a certain amount you know you you have
to figure out what your resources are
some people have a lot of resources some
people have no resources and it's not
fair I'm here to tell you it is not fair
some people have a lot of resources they
have a lot of money they have that their
dads in the entertainment business
they're someone's rich or they give you
know it's not fair this is not a fair
game out here it's just and if people
come out here thinking it's a fair
playing field then they're they're in
for an rude awakening the key is to
figure out what your resources are what
you have access to and to make the best
of it and if you're able to do that
sooner or later I feel like your
resources are going to grow and the your
outreach are going to grow but if you
spend all your time wallowing in the
fact that you don't have what someone
else has or their Outreach or their com
their uh their ability to um get more
money or get more exposure that's the
way then then you're already dead in the
water because that's the way it's always
going to be period it's not level not a
fair playing field out here in La
particular any yeah in LA in particular
I think that applies to life but in the
entertainment business it's certainly
not a fair playing field at all I
mean you
know how do you explain movie stars kids
starring in movies couldn't they I'm
sure there's another Young young actor
who's probably just as good or better
but no you know it's nepotism it's who
you know and and I think that works for
a while until it doesn't and a lot of
deserving people who work their asses
off do not get opportunities because
they're pushed out of the club because
they don't know enough people but you
know you know I'm under the mentality
I'm going to fight you know I'm the I'm
the guy that's standing in line waiting
for the guy in the club to uh who's been
there so long he either he dies or he uh
he goes to a different Club you know I'm
like a life you know I I you know
whatever happens with me in my life in
my career you know I'm not going away
I'm just I'm going to keep doing this so
going back to still City when you were
laying in bed thinking about it how much
Obsession you talked about that
Obsession I think is really
interesting I mean can you talk about
like how much of your waking time was
spent because so many people have these
great movie ideas myself included and we
don't do anything with them so what was
the difference like you
said I honestly thought and I was
obsessed I I was like I I thought I I
convinced myself I was going to die if I
didn't make the movie I thought I was
going to get struck by a fatal disease
if I didn't figure out a way to make the
movie that I would I would it would
either happen now or like I just
pictured myself like laying on my
deathbed thinking I didn't make steel
city I didn't have the guts and I didn't
I didn't do it and I just told myself I
said if this movie kills me I have to
get it made and you know if I if I bug
you know if I have to rob a bank to get
the money to make this movie I hope I
can shoot it before I go to trial and
that's the type of stuff I was thinking
like I was obsessed with it and I think
that that can be a turnoff but when
you're young and you're passionate you
can you kind of have some leeway way you
can't really on your fifth film like you
know you're not a kid anymore I've been
you know I'm going to turn 35 this year
so you have to like be a little bit more
strategic but when you're young and you
know um I think you know I was just I
mean obsessed I thought I was going to
lose my life if I didn't get the film
made I mean Ser that's not an
understatement I thought if I didn't get
the film made I was going to commit
suicide that's how obsessed I
was seriously oh wow I
yeah I bet all the money I have most of
the
time if the film doesn't do I start from
scratch again I've done it a couple of
times I I don't enjoy it very
much and you're able to sleep at night
oh yes
okay because to begin with I never had
this money everything else was
bonus so
account can't complain Justin what was
your Breaking Point lowest moment with
killing Winston Jones where you came
close to
quitting that's a great question
I don't know the exact point to be
honest I think as writers we work our
best to bury some of the difficult
moments and try to remember the positive
moments a little bit more um to be
optimistic and excited about you know
the potential of what we're working on
um but off hand I would say
probably uh the third and final time
that we lost
financing um I just think that Joel and
I uh our director Joel and I had put in
so much time and effort into getting
this script where it needed to be and we
put in you know two years of our life
nonstop and really exhausted our
resources at that point and I think we
were just feeling beaten down down we'd
worked so hard especially with this last
production company where the financing
fell through so I think I that was the
hardest moment just because I felt like
if I wasn't the cheerleader anymore
everyone else could potentially walk
away and even the producers that we had
at that point that were working on other
projects or some of the actors that said
that they would you know that were
verbally attached I could just see that
it looked like it was at a place where
it could potentially Fall Apart and this
the toughest part also is that getting
back to what we were talking about with
packaging is that when you do package a
film that package so often changes
because you can get an incredible actor
who's attached themselves but if they're
a great actor chances are they're on a
lot of different projects and their
schedules change so I knew that some of
the great actors that we had you know
the interest from dry Fist and the
interest from Glover and and from
Masterson and heater and everything
everybody else was limited and if we
weren't going to be able to get it done
this year chances were we were going to
lose all if you know most if not all of
those actors and um so I think that was
the toughest point I think if you asked
my wife she could probably tell you more
specifically um because you know your
significant other has to live with you
through those moments those moments that
you're extremely excited about but also
those moments where um you're kind of um
at the bottom so
uh yeah I would say it's probably when
we lost the financing for the third and
final time and little did I know that
you know 48 hours later we got financing
and we were going to
pre-production so in that 24th hour
before you knew maybe I don't and I'm
not sure the exact timeline but how did
you kind of pick yourself up what was
your selft talk knowing that you were
sort of like the patriarch of the family
you you know you're trying to hold it
together and if your mood sours then it
takes it all down I think uh you have to
find distractions and find outlets and
things you know I think it's healthy to
have outlets in any capacity in life you
know I'm a writer first and foremost but
that's not all that you know I'm known
for that I want to be known for that I
want to do you know I I also um you know
I love uh you know seeing movies I love
listening to music I love you know
painting I love reading I love all these
other things so I think really at my
worst moments I'm probably distracting
myself with something else that is at
least making me happy um but I don't
think that I ever really completely gave
up I don't think you can give up the
people who give up aren't in the
industry anymore they're not writing
anymore you know you don't you don't
give up on projects you keep pushing
them through I mean uh the projects that
I don't have success with that don't end
up making it onto the screen till the
day I die I'll still be pushing them and
trying to make them on the screen you
know I'll never shove something and
never go back to it so I think there's a
time and a place for everything um and
you know I I think that uh I still
fighting for killing Winston Jones you
know there's still challenges that we
have to go through I I can't say that
there won't be another time when maybe I
think that the film isn't going to make
it in the theaters or isn't going to get
accepted in the film festivals there's
going to be tragic moments along the way
and difficult moments along the way too
but it's just staying positive so I
think that you allow yourself to have
those moments where you feel the
depression and you feel upset about the
bad things that have happened but know
that uh you can easily climb out of that
and it's something that I said before
about um distractions with other
projects you know killing Winston Jones
was difficult because I had all my eggs
in one bask at that point because I
hadn't really written a lot of other
things but now that I have you know two
other features I have um a short that
I'm adapting I have a TV show that I'm
working on like those there's always at
least one thing good that's happening to
keep me positive you know um and or
something on the horizon at least so I
think that there's no reason to always
or to ever be down completely know
something should be able to lift you up
and get you out of that and you know
that 24th hour passed and we were flying
you know on the next flight out to
Savannah Georgia to make the movie so
you know and that's and that's what I
remember that's why this question was
hard to answer because I can't remember
the lowest point because it's replaced
by
you know uh working on set with drus you
know or or learning about acting and
writing from Danny Glover and his
experiences or having dinner with the
entire you know crew almost every night
that we were there and those
relationships that we built so those
easily replace the difficult
times where does someone go to figure
that out it's interesting movie sets and
just be sort of in the background no you
got to do your own I mean I just
personally believe if you want to be a
film director you need to just be a film
director and there's no limitations all
you need is a 5D you know you don't even
need a 5D you need an iPhone I guarantee
you if you
make a really fascinating script and
shoot it on
iPhone people will watch it and your
next film will be bigger you know it's I
think the problem is when people come in
expecting to make Apocalypse Now on
their first go you know it's it's
probably not going to happen you know
you need to start small and and figure
yourself out and allow yourself the
opportunity to mess up and do it again
if you mess
up and also you said know who you are
you would only really find that out in
sort of the Heat of the Moment behind
the camera with yeah whether it's just
two people in a park or I think there's
something about our culture that um has
us thinking that we can figure out who
we are inside of our heads but that's
not how it happens or at least that's
not how it happened for me I think the
way you figure yourself out is by doing
things and by being in relation to other
people and as a filmmaker the way you
figure yourself out is by making things
and failing or succeeding
and finishing the film and showing it to
strangers and seeing how they react to
it and how they feel about it I think
that's the only way to to really figure
out who you are and what you have to
offer because
um if not it's just inside of your head
it doesn't it doesn't really mean
anything in the greater context of the
world but we all want to just do it in
our heads cuz it's
safer so you did a great interview on
the Huff Post Live that I watched and
you said that so many people see the end
result of films the walking the right
carpet all dressed up and and it looks
so wonderfully easy what would you want
people to know about this project and
all of the hard work you're doing behind
the
scenes well I mean I I don't really
think I think that knowing for the
general audience knowing too much about
the Blood Sweat and Tears go on behind
the scenes would kind of lessen the
movie Magic experience for people but I
think that
there when the criticism comes in about
oh well you just do that and you just so
easy to do that and you're so lucky
because you have that or blah blah blah
blah
blah there is so much work and there's
so much disappointment and there's so
much insecurity and there's so much you
know fighting but fighting this good
cause and getting very like excited
about it and then going downhill because
it doesn't then you have your time
you're your own you know captain of your
ship
and I mean making an independent movie
is very complicated thing at any time
but in this time especially and they say
oh well you know you can shoot it on 5D
and you can do this yeah sure I can do
all of these things and I will do all of
these things but I shouldn't just be you
know regulated to like I don't know an
independent film is a really you know
it's it's independent film means very
little money it means but very little
money often leads to much more
creativity and that's what I'm
interested in I'm not interested in the
kind of a general story I want to fight
the good fight I want it to get ugly and
I want I think people want that you know
but it's not especially doing things
uglier especially doing things out of
the general realm of how you know that
people can't say oh well I saw that and
that must be like that so then I can
watch this and it's you know it's about
taking a chance and you know so I it's a
lot of struggle and you know I if I had
the check to write out my own movie I
would absolutely do it you know a few
months ago not now but you know I'm an
independent filmmaker and I come from an
independent film family where we all you
know work really hard to make the art
and get to struggle and you know
sometimes you're broke and sometimes you
have money and you know that's the way
it goes but it's there's nothing secure
about it you really have to be kind of
like strong and you know it's a really
strange life but also it's such a
rewarding life that you take the good
with the
bad I still feel like I've been gladly
and I if the rest of my career goes like
this I'd be happy like working kind of
under the radar for a bit you know I've
kind of always had to try to find my own
way to get these films made you know
I've always it's always come together in
some really sort of strange
untraditional way after like 3 years of
people telling me no like both my movies
have been that path and so I feel like
I've had to I've had to find it and
build it for myself which I've been
happy to but I also but I don't I
haven't had like an accidental thing yet
you know I haven't had that sort of like
where I made something I didn't think
people were going to see and a ton of
people saw it you know it hasn't hasn't
really been that yet but maybe it hasn't
I just don't realize it you know I mean
I think I think my first film maybe is
an indication of that like it didn't it
didn't get into Sundance didn't get into
South by Southwest it didn't get into
Tribeca it didn't get into I mean any of
the major us festivals and it felt like
it was going to totally disappear you
know it kind of felt like I made this
thing I'm proud of it I feel like it's
good I feel like I can stand by it but
like no one is going to play it anywhere
and um and then we got you know we got
an opportunity to screen at C Vegas
which doesn't exist anymore but at the
time was notable you know enough to get
the movie on the radar and then and then
the movie ended up getting two spirit
Award nominations so it ended up
building to something you know so I
think as opposed to maybe something
being like a snapping point or like a
big break or like this big opportunity
it just happening I think it's happening
very slowly and I'm working really hard
for it and I hope that um like I said if
I if I keep on making movies the same
way I've been making them and I keep on
falling under the radar like I'm I'm I'm
fine with that to me I just want to make
movies I don't want to you know as long
as each each film I feel like lens it's
he the opportunity to get to make the
next one so that's that's what I'm
hoping for you know I I don't know if
I'll ever be like a big uh a big break
like that but I mean getting into to
Sundance is and I think in a weird way
maybe not getting to Sundance was like
it gave me a lot of perspective um a lot
of appreciation for when I did get to
play there um if it been my first time I
think I would have been thrilled but I
think it would have maybe I wouldn't
have understand stood how hard it can
really be to get to play a movie there
you know and and just and a lot of
people I know just cuz you played one
movie there doesn't mean your next one's
necessarily going to play there you know
and the other way around so there's not
there's no guarantee and I I think I
went in with that appreciation and S of
said okay hey I'm really I felt really
lucky you know I I felt like I didn't
feel like I paid my d with my first
movie and got an opportunity to now but
I just felt like I got a chance to
screen it there and this particular
movie appealed to them in a specific way
and um and that's great and whether I
ever hopefully get a chance to play
another movie there but if not I I did
have that one experience which I always
wanted so we kind of jumped out there on
our own credit cards we didn't have
funding in place and everything and the
first time I saw a little clip that
Ramona put together I said we have to do
this and she's like well they're on tour
right now and I said right now we were
standing in a u Starbucks parking lot
she said yeah I said we're missing the
story it's unfolding like we have to go
now and she was like well we don't have
money and I said well we can't let that
stop us don't let that stop us so within
a week of that conversation we were on
the road just like putting stuff on
credit cards and and we just always knew
and there was one moment you know
because we were so small and we didn't
have a lot of money there was only five
of us on a road so there's two camera
operators one sound Rona and myself and
my job was always sort of to to PA and
you know to drive and just dump footage
and just do kind of all the things
anything else that you know needed to be
done and I remember at one point we were
probably like maybe at the six venue and
I was sitting back there and it kind of
dawned on me I said we're like charging
up a storm we're following a rock band
we don't have any money we don't know
what the movie is we don't know anything
we're just out here and I watched like
10 minutes of our na in the dressing
room and he would he captivated me I
couldn't take my eyes off of him and
that's what I knew I was like we're
going to be all right like I knew we're
going to be all right so what are some
of your mantras or or your ways of
working through it because I know
there's so many times when you probably
just want to just abandon something but
you can't we all go through it with
stuff so what what keeps you on track so
that you don't yeah that's a good
question so you don't give up basically
yeah yeah that's a good question um I I
love what's his name Steven do you guys
know the book um the war of art is it
Steven prfi pressfield right okay um um
yeah I love the book uh the war of art
by Steven pressfield um that that has a
great prescription for getting through
writer block and you know you can sort
of pull from that to apply to any sort
of challenge that you're meeting along
the production phase um and his advice I
think you know the bottom line is in
order to beat writer block you simply
have to continue writing you know and
you write each and every day and the
only way around it is to go through it
you know um
and so another thing another thing that
I found myself telling myself a lot um
through lourus was who's going to tell
the story um if I give up what's going
to happen to the story um if I'm not
around to put my Blood Sweat and Tears
into this film then no one else will and
no one will have the the priv privilege
of of hearing about this amazing man and
his amazing accomplishments and you know
I feel like the world would have missed
out if they didn't get introduced to
joose we in this way um and so yeah
there's this obligation to to do the
story Justice and to tell the story
properly um that that is a pretty good
motivating factor I think for me so
really having a sense of purpose with it
not just oh I want to win this award or
hoping to get into Sundance but really
having that sense of purpose behind the
actual yeah the awards the awards just
can't drive you you know what I mean
because because they rarely come um and
when they do they're really not all that
rewarding you know and uh what you find
I think at the end of the process is
what's the most rewarding thing is is
the feeling of accomplishing um this
great feat of actually finishing a film
and then sharing it with people sharing
with audiences and and um and watching
the sort of ripple effect that takes
place when you finish a film uh the
people that are affected and inspired
and and in some cases the actual change
that takes place takes place as far as
you know policy or in our case it was a
a a village of 5,000 people getting
water for the first time in their lives
and so that's really the most rewarding
thing of making movies I think is
watching that ripple effect Judy I saw a
quote from you somewhere where it said
never give up or stop dreaming you may
have to do a lot less meaningful work
along the way to sustain yourself but
you have to hold on to your dreams I
think that's a boat that a lot of Indie
people whether it's music whatever are
in can you tell us about some of the
times that you had to do some less
meaningful work and how you kept sort of
that prize of what you really wanted in
the back of your mind to keep you
going well uh the the phrase less
meaningful is is is relative because it
may be less meaningful to you
artistically and soulfully but there's
another part of the business there are
several parts of the business that you
have to take care of and one of them is
to learn how to sustain yourself
financially how to make a living in the
business and what it takes to do that
and the things that are most satisfying
to your heart and soul are not the
things that are generally going to bring
you the most money so I have at times
taken jobs on television shows mostly
where um either I wasn't enthralled with
the subject matter or it wasn't
something that represented how I felt
about things but nevertheless there was
a lot to learn from it and just learning
how to operate in that world uh learning
what it takes to make a product get to
Market and what it takes to sustain a
product uh these are all valuable
lessons so when I would go into one of
these
projects I would look for the thing in
it that I didn't know that I would learn
from
it and on that level I could always find
a way to enjoy what I was doing
sometimes it would get to me after a
long time um because being a woman
director what was offered to me a lot of
times was um more reality oriented
things and some of them had gruesome
subject matter that I really wasn't
something I wanted to deal with you know
sometimes it would get to
me and if it got to me too much I'd walk
I'd say you know this is not for me
anymore but finding ways to learn
something on every project that I was on
getting something out of it making more
Connections in the world advancing my
career in other
ways those were things that I learned
from having to do things that weren't
from my heart so why was it so important
for you to keep this promise because it
sounds like it wasn't an easy Road and
we can go into more of that later but I
would love to just talk about your need
to keep your word and you know in
especially in entertainment that doesn't
always happen yeah what was so important
to you to keep your word with this like
why I think it's just something I've
grown up with
um I went through the Boy Scouts and got
my Eagle Scout award um and it's just
something that is instilled in you um
and so I
think you know one of the Scout Law
principles is is trustworthy so you know
here I am being trusted to to finish
this thing and I I shook hands I gave my
word so every time I looked about you
looked at quitting or looked at like
moving on or doing something else or
like just sending an email and being
like it's just not going to happen I
didn't and I was just like you know I
gave my word I got to push through I got
to finish whatever it is I got to get
through whatever unbelievable drama gets
put in front of me there has to be a
solution somewhere uh
and so I did and I just kept pushing on
and kept pushing on and and got through
it and how long was the process again uh
well we shot the film in August 2008
August and September and had our world
premiere in January 200 or in March 2013
okay so good fiveyear fiveyear effort
and then you know after our Premiere
getting the DVD out and you know here we
are in April 2014 so congratulations wow
and I can see how proud you are when you
hold up up that beautiful DVD yeah the
DVD is awesome man there's uh a lot of
extras in a menu and it's really nice so
what did the whole process teaching you
excuse me what did the whole process
teach you about not quitting about
staying the
course uh
well I I think about that a lot I think
about well what what you know I I think
ultimately like sometimes it's not the
best decision
to keep a
promise really I
think you know
um sometimes it is best
to
um just just call it and and and do
something else because I feel like
several years of my life have been um
involved in getting this thing finished
and I've I've passed on amazing amazing
opportunities that'll never get back you
know amazing travel opportunities and
shooting the World Cup down in South
Africa and traveling and
um of course you balance it all right
like now it's done and you're like wow
it would have never gotten
finished if I didn't stay with it
but it's hard to it's hard to look back
and say what you would change or what
you would do differently of course in
the moment you're always making the best
decision you can and in the moment I
always felt like I can't give up I can't
give up I can't give up so and sort of
there there's this motto or this advice
don't give up don't give up don't give
up so in my mind I'm always like wow I
should just follow that I should just
follow that I should just follow that
so was there ever a time that you wanted
to turn back and go home yeah there
were
um I got offered to direct like two
feature films before compound fracture
and they both fell through and it was
just like such a heartbreaking
experience to get it all the way to
where they even wrote me a check and I
had a check in my hand I went to the
bank and it bounced and then the person
disappear this happened twice in fact
one time I actually was at the bank with
the person while it bounced and I got so
upset with this person this was like
maybe four or five years ago I just let
him have it I lost it I like Snapped
everything that I had had difficulties
with to that point culminated into this
moment and I just snapped on this guy I
feel bad now but I I was like a 25 or 26
year old kid and I made this 40 some
year old gentleman cry in the bank and I
felt certain Victory because I actually
told him what I he needed to hear but at
the same time I felt a little bit bad
about that because I reached a point
where whatever it was that was going on
pushed me to the point where I was doing
that and I felt like
maybe this business ain't for me I don't
know if I want to become a person that
can do this kind of a thing and I felt
bad about it for a while but I realized
that and I look back on it I'm like man
that guy really screwed me though I
spent so much time and I as so many
people favors to get this guy's movie
made and I was going to direct it and it
fell through and everybody got screwed
it sucked I felt really bad about it so
I the guy did kind of deserve it and as
much as I feel bad about that and I've
kind of like
morally felt a little bit you know
regretful that I said some of the things
I said to that guy I learned from that
experience and I
think I understood
that it's going to be hard if not
impossible to get what you want out of
this business unless you really have the
ability to push through those moments
when it's the hardest thing for you in
the world and you feel like just crushed
if you can push past that
I think you have what it takes to stay
in this industry I've had friends that
have fallen off and I don't blame one
bit I feel like I kind of wish I did
fall off at one point because I've had
to go through some pretty intense
experiences in my life as a result of
choosing this career path but you know
then you look at it like well at least
I'm at least I'm doing what I love and I
can and I'm safe you know I have a lot
of friends that are in the military and
they have to do things that threaten
their life every day but they still do
it and if they got if those guys can do
it and they're in their heart they're
willing to put forth that kind of effort
you know what I have my problems in my
life are so minus School compared to
that and I I can't even compare it and
it's just
like you know you start to think about
things like that and you're like of
course I'm going to keep going why
not do you know what I mean it's just
like
a everybody like there's always somebody
else out there that's got a lot worse
than you do
so you just got to remember
that even you know the first day of
production actually uh we were working
in Savannah Georgia as I had mentioned
it's a right to work state we weren't
unionized across the board so of course
we had SAG we were ATL unionized so
everything above the line uh was
unionized we were sag but some of our
other departments weren't completely
unionized so I don't know exactly which
ones they were I feel like it might have
been makeup or hair or or uh costume
design but on the very first day of
production um the unions and the
teamster showed up on set and were
picketing and they told our crew that
they would have uh they would be fined
$5,000 for working on the film that they
would have their um cards revoked that
they wouldn't work in this town again
and although that's not true because
Georgia is a right- to work state so
technically you can shoot a film that's
not entirely unionized uh but they did
enough damage where half of our crew was
scared and they left and so we lost an
entire day and our production company
had to decide if they were going
to uh pay to unionize which is a you
know six fig decision and if they were
going to push production forward and for
several hours we thought that we were
going to be shutting down completely but
luckily we had a strong production
company behind us that
uh that paid that difference and and the
wages for everyone who is working for
for us became unionized and increased
and we made the film um you know so that
was just another challenge and
throughout the process of of production
there's challenges every single day you
know um and even into post- production
it's it's a lot of creative people
working together um and at the end of
the day it's it's a business so you have
different mentalities you have people
who want to create the best creative
process uh and and product and film and
then you have people that want to make
as much money as they possibly can so
even in post- production we have people
seeing differently you know on on the
same project and uh we just have to find
a middle ground so that we can get it
released and and it'll be the challenges
that we have finding distribution you
know getting into the film festivals
that we want to get into and uh getting
into the amount of theaters and and
hopefully doing well with the film so
every single corner is is
every single corner and every day is a
challenge and getting a film done the
other day I was trying to figure out you
know what exactly I do you know um you
know I've done like 25 Mo feature films
you know but um if you really analyze
what exactly I do like 9 to 10 whatever
I put in 12 hours a day all my life 99%
of the time in spending in trying to
make a movie it's not actually making
the movie the actual time that you make
the movie when you're on a set making
the movie is like the vacation that's
like that's like that's like the the
vacation you you get for the hard work
that you have to put into it it's so
hard yeah and you know and and and I
think that's sort of in a way it's the
tragedy of a lot of filmmakers that this
is what we have to do that you know
there's very few filmmakers who actually
are able to have a different balance
where they say I spent 50% of my life
actually shooting and another 50%
putting movies together those are rare
exceptions you know and those are the
gods that we look up to whether it's
Woody Allen or Spielberg or they
actually seem to spend 50% of their
energy and life and work into actually
making a movie but for most of us we
spend 99% of our time trying to make a
movie you know trying to get the money
trying to do this to convince people to
you know and it's it's sort of sad
because at the end of your life you sort
of look man you know all the movies I I
would have I was ready to make and
wanted to make and only did a little
fraction because it just took all this
effort just to do anything Gary from
looking you up online I know a big thing
for you is not accepting the word
no and and it thank goodness it seems
like a lot of things have come your way
by you continuing to push forward when
should someone actually accept that word
is there is there a number of ter let's
define our terms I'm not sure that one
should ever accept the word no I I I I
really mean that it's it I I I I once
gave a talk the title of which was no is
just a conversation starter and that's
really what I believe it to be when
someone says no to me I haven't done my
job it's a clue I should tell a more
persuasive story take a deeper cut knock
on more doors there's something I'm not
doing to get the yes and they're helping
me by saying you're not there yet that's
exactly how I view and
know in the film industry your life is
all about no you get NOS yeah I'm not
telling anyone anything they don't know
they've all experienced this we all
experien it and at times it feels very
harsh and personal and and and defeating
but I really don't I I don't want to
waste my time uh feeling blue about
people not lining up behind me it just
every every time I hear a note it it
just incites me to push harder and be
better and and speak more uh crisply and
authentically so you can't saying though
if I can be undeniable that that's my
job that's all of our job is is to tell
people who we really are why we really
want what we want uh it's not just a
script for God's sakes this is a story
that needs to be told I'm the only one
who can do it this is why this is the
team I've assembled whatever it
is um so and and and my gosh for every
film that I've gotten produced there are
so many dead projects on the floor that
ultimately did die but if I took no for
an answer I'd never produce a
film we've always heard that a Hallmark
of a great entrepreneur is being
irritated by the fact that someone would
tell them they can't do something
because it lights a fire in them is
there a way to do it without that
negative sort of oh I'll show them or
maybe that's a good thing I don't think
it's negative um I'm a very stubborn
individual and I used to think
that uh there were there were traits
that I always thought that could
negative but it's not a great friend of
mine a brilliant businessman long ago
very successful taught me that you need
your PhD pigheaded determination right
and it's true well there's a balance you
know because there there can be if if
you're driven that way I mean you
shouldn't want to do a thing just to
make other people wrong you should want
to do it because it's that important to
you you do have to listen you have to
understand the difference between
valuable feedback or
critique and and someone who's just not
getting the
vision and if you get if you get yeah I
I get a lot of NOS where I don't hear
the no but I do hear oh my God that was
a great piece of insight that was a
great bit of advice or they so totally
didn't see what I was getting at here I
better tweak that piece so yeah there
there's a lot of learning in there um
but I I don't I don't think you stay
stubborn just to be stubborn I think
it's because you really believe in
something and there are enough people
who also see what you see that you're
not just
scaming palmertown USA was a hit show on
I think
CBS uh Alex hilly and Norman leer couple
of
Seasons making great money High
lifestyle I said okay now i' done this I
proved myself as an
actor didn't work for two
years it's like made me
really question my
talent quit acting went to the American
Film
Institute American Film Institute uh
made a film there and short and called
the hero got Awards and
stuff nobody would buy it nobody would
take me as an actor as a director got
depressed went away to a Meditation
Retreat David Jake um my agent calls me
and says come into right away um to cuz
David Jos wants to see you um possibly
shoot not Landing I was there I went
back drove so fast got back on Monday I
was in David Jacob's office he and I
talked said Thank you went home got to
call for my agent you're hired not I
called everybody I knew man it's just
like heaven heaven
heaven uh Joe wallenstein the producer
on my last day of prep coming office
office his office and said Bill great
prep we know you would make it man cuz
you're great good you could tell by
you're real I said what real I said well
the Reel that you sent us from your
other
shows said I said I just got a AFI man I
just got my he says wait a minute goes
in David jacobs's office David Jacobs
had mixed my box up with somebody else's
so I got hired by mistake so they
followed me around for the first three
days once they know what I was
doing that was one of the higher points
of my career because it was like I I
mean I got multiple episodes of that
show and multiple other shows and based
upon that particular Triumph for
me and that was so I was a low and then
I came to a high then I directed like
you know Sister Act 2 and other films in
hoodlum
and movies but you know it's
like you think okay I've proven myself
here but if it doesn't make the ex a
certain amount of money no matter if it
if it breaks even makes a certain
problem profet okay
but for most of us that are black
directors in this industry if it doesn't
just blow the roof off it's
uh not
easy Alexis at what point in your life
did you decide you wanted to make films
you've you've been in research and
you've done composing and you've worked
with wave theory and things that are
just beyond my comprehension but what
made you want to go in the direction of
film making well I've I've always been
interested in film making and um I found
it I've always found it fascinating for
reasons I'd never quite understood but I
um I would read uh biographies of um
various filmmakers the famous directors
and so forth um but a point that a point
came in my composing where I thought
well I've got an unusual approach to
composition so I'm um I'm combining kind
of elements of science and Technology
with elements of art and I began to
think I wonder if this could be used in
a film because I've always loved film
I've always wanted the chance to make a
film um but can you really do that can
you because all of my
compositions you know they happen lives
they have some elements say subatomic
particles in the violin live or uh
Making Waves in a wave pool turn into
Music Live film isn't a live
medium it it you know film is fixed and
you show it and um then at it was about
2 years ago um or maybe a year and a
half ago that I
thought why does it have to be a fixed
medium why can't it actually change um
why can't you have a film that changed
while people are watching it and it was
at that point about a year and a half
ago that I actually thought I really
could make a film here
because it's my desire to make a film
coming at the same time as my
realization of how myque unique skill
set could bring something new to making
a
film what would you advise other people
who are Professionals in one Arena of
their life and then later on decide to
maybe not switch careers entirely but
add something new to their plate how do
they begin how do they compartmentalize
their life well that's that's a very
interesting question actually because I
um there's been kind of two situations
there was obviously that situation with
making a fail
um and at the point of deciding to make
a film it took a a bit of a leap of
faith really it was a kind of I can do
this if I get the right team on board um
with the music uh that was a bigger
decision because that had been something
running in the background through my
life since my early teens and it was
only when I was um in my
mid-30s um that I I decided I've got to
change you know I was working on Wall
Street and um and I I I had the best job
I could imagin having um and then I
actually switched to working for a
startup and I and you know trying to
become rich through a tech startup but
the point came when I thought this I'm
I'm not starting my new career I'm not I
knew I either wanted to write or do
music I knew I wanted to do something
more creative and it wasn't happening I
was trying to be a singer songwriter I
was trying to um compose um electronic
dance music you know I'm trying to come
up with that magic disc that I could
then release to the world to show what I
could do and somebody would give me the
platform or the money or or the the the
the way to to do this and it and it
wasn't nothing was happening and I
wasn't sure what to do and then I
thought I've got to change my life I
have to change I can only change my
career if I change my life um and so I
um I I thought well what could I do well
what I originally was going to do is do
a music degree this is where luck comes
into it as well good fortune if you want
to call it I decided I want to do a
music degree that'll make a big
shift and
then um I couldn't get on the music
degree I wanted to because they were
moving it down the country too far away
I didn't want to travel I searched at a
closer
University and by chance I saw they had
a PhD in computer music
available um at the University in my
town There's and there's not that many
computer music research groups around
the country in the UK so this is the
Good Fortune coming into it and and of
course starting on a PhD you start much
higher up the ladder and in computer
music composition is often a very strong
element in the academic study so um I
decided I'm going to stop this job that
I'm doing which was the best paid job i'
I'd ever had um and I'm going to divide
my salary to a third of its current
value um I did have a little help I must
admit from my family so I had some
family help but not a huge amount just a
small amount um and and I I started at
the bottom again it wasn't quite the
bottom because it was a postgrad degree
but um it was starting again and uh that
was the big decision was was being
willing to lower the salary uh and and
start
again I think at some point you have to
find the courage to stand up and say
look this is not a hobby this is not a
lark this is my career I may not be
making money at it yet but this is what
I want to do with my life and I need
your respect for that you don't have to
do anything but you have to honor it and
let me make that a priority some of the
time that's tough it comes back to that
fear and courage thing but you're going
to have to find that courage because
it's a lot less painful than not finding
it and 40 years later or 30 years later
looking back and saying gee I wonder
what would have happened if I had done
what I really wanted to do and you wrote
about a similar situation on your blog
right oh yeah because I had recently
gotten an email like that and there was
um a a young man I don't recall I I I
think he was in college studying
something that his parents had wanted
him to study and he hated it and he told
them as passionately as he could I
really want to write I want to write and
then I want to be a filmmaker and they
like were threatening to disown him and
they said you can't do that so he tolded
the mark and he thought I'll do it on my
spare time and I'll go ahead and do what
they want which is go to I think it was
lost school or pre-law and he was so
miserable that he got an ulcer and he
according to his email and eventually he
started taking drugs he became an
alcoholic he got on drugs he had to go
into rehab and he almost died and that
finally was the wakeup call to him and
he said I can't I can't I literally
can't live like this I'm not going to
survive this so that gave him
the courage and the support because of
the rehab and the and the program and so
on to finally go after the thing he
wanted to go after it's it's a tough
thing it's a very tough sad situation
but at the end of the day you got to do
what the hero of a movie has to do and
that is if you want it bad enough you
got to overcome those deep-seated fears
and somehow find the courage to step up
well I don't want to make a blanket
statements
about independent filmmakers but I've
had students who are
lazy and laziness is something I really
can't
tolerate
so because of laziness I think that that
speaks of a sense of
entitlement
and that's just not a good look in this
industry where you think that you
entitled to something that you you
deserve something because you're
wherever you think you are it doesn't
work like that another thing I like to
add is that and I'm I'm speaking about
my school a lot of
people come out
NYU thinking that because you have this
degree from this prestigious prestigious
institution NYU or USC or AFI Colombia
in the real world they don't really give
a
you know if you don't have the
talent that degree doesn't mean a thing
when you come out of school you should
have if you're director you should have
a film you're DP you should have a real
editor should have a
real if you're screen right should have
scripts so people want people really
want to
see the
work you've
done if someone wasn't able to attend
film school is there a crash course that
you would give like what would your
syllabus be in terms camera learn how to
use it yeah I think one of the most
important things that you can do as a
filmmaker is is learn the technology
because as it's becoming easier for an
independent filmmaker to you know even
just do a vlog with their webcam and
throw it up and become a celebrity on
YouTube you know the the takeaways the
easier it becomes and the cheaper it
becomes to create your own content the
more an artist has to be a business
person and a technical person at the the
same time in order to be successful and
I think that owning a camera or having
access to a camera and understanding how
to use it understanding the technical
aspects of
production is really really really
important and you can subsidize your
habit by getting jobs that involve
essentially renting your equipment
that's what a lot of lot of people who
are Indie freelance Etc do also watch
movies or TV like whatever it is that
you want to do consume a lot
thing we meet people at film school who
like didn't watch movies or didn't like
movies um and that doesn't help you
right um I think you know for us YouTube
really took off you know when we were in
our maybe first or second year of school
and first of all USC at the time I don't
think this is the case anymore but and
it wasn't just USC specifically films up
yeah films schools were very against uh
putting videos on the internet there
were a couple reasons why you know there
were you know if you're going to be a
dumb kid and use copywritten stuff we
don't want to get sued because of it but
there's also you know uh them not
wanting to launch you until you're ready
um a lot of what film School used to be
was an arena for you to fail in private
as you were learning how to become a
better filmmaker but the reality is
everyone now must fail in public and
it's it's sort of an interesting world
because you want to be proud of your
thing and put it up and think it's good
but what if it doesn't land you know
that is something that in the past you
would have you know a school to critique
that and it wouldn't go anywhere and the
only time that anyone would actually see
it is if it was good enough to be seen
you didn't have you know an internet uh
littered with the corpses of dead social
media and YouTube accounts that didn't
really work out and that's the reality
now and I think in some ways it's good
because not only is there some kind of
accountability but you know a lot
Hollywood has often run on a myth of the
wonderkind and the overnight success and
you know you the the common joke is you
work really really really hard for years
to be an overnight success and there's a
lot of that process that people don't
see and it becomes really discouraging
to people because they think like oh my
first feature screenplay isn't getting
sold you know what am I doing wrong that
you know Quenton Tarantino did right and
the reality is is you know people write
and write and write and write and write
but it just doesn't get seen and now
that you're seeing those those learning
processes in public I think it gives a
lot more um inspiration to people that
they can actually get somewhere you know
even if you look at a a popular YouTube
channel these people started somewhere
if you go back to their very first video
and you compare the very first video to
the most recent video if it's someone
very popular there's going to be a huge
change people don't just come out of the
woodwork perfectly and
um I think you know under understanding
that is much more valuable than film
school I think that um you know I I've
met with a lot of film teachers that
don't really know what they're supposed
to be teaching these days and I think
that what a film school can give you is
still valuable but I think that it's
changing and in terms of I want to be a
filmmaker what is the best way to for me
to be a filmmaker you know create
content create content constantly and
show it to people on a regular basis
seek feedback for your work change it
when people don't respond to it well and
try to understand why people aren't
responding to it you know iterate
iterate iterate is essentially what
you're doing you know
the saying of you have to do 10,000
hours about of something to be good at
it you do your 10,000 hours of YouTube
video and you will eventually reach a
spot where you're actually good at it
advice to those fork in the road folks
that they've built up some stability in
their lives they've built up a few years
so they have some life experience but
they also know they have some
obligations what's sort of a little
checklist and and and I don't think
you're being discouraging in all I think
you're actually being uh you know quite
encouraging because I mean life's
expensive things cost money and but at
the same time knowing that you also want
to live a life that's fulfilling right
so what would you tell let's suppose
there's a fork in the road couple right
now and you're just medium for coffee
what would you tell them um I've had
this conversation many times and
whenever I'm sitting at someone who's
sort of standing between where they are
now and and and and their first film or
their first Passion project you I I
don't want to limit it just to films
because for a lot of people it's it's it
maybe it's writing their first
screenplay maybe
it's producing their first television
pilot or any number of sort of ambitious
projects not just featurelength films um
there's that expression
go big or go home um I think you should
go small or go home on your first
project do something that that is not so
ambitious that you're not going to make
it to the Finish Line because I the only
thing worse than a film that's not you
know that's maybe not as successful as
the filmmaker had hoped is a film that
doesn't get
finished I mean that's just the thought
of that like rips my heart out you know
you get a film that's halfway done and
then you walk away from it or a
screenplay that's 2third of the way done
and they didn't quite finish for
whatever
reason I mean that's if you're going to
really take that leap do something that
you
know you have the ability to finish
um you either you need to you need to
have a great story that you love that
you're in love with um you need to have
the technical chops to see it through to
the end
um you need Partners if you don't have
all the funding or or all the pieces
that are important make sure you have
them um
and maybe more important most
importantly is you need friends and
colleagues who are willing to look at
early Cuts or read early versions of a
screenplay and tell you if it's any good
or not I mean that's really important um
we had all those things when we made our
first first film um and probably more
important than anything my brother and
my best friend encouraged us to take
that leap and said look we have a little
bit of money we can lend you some money
to get the ball rolling which they did
and um and and that was tremendously
helpful we paid them back I wrote my I
wrote my brother a check for $100,000
after we sold word play which is really
felt great um and and I think the last
thing thing I mean the one other thing I
would I would encourage people to do is
to really constrain
themselves give yourself a time limit
give yourself some deadlines and work
within them so when we started word play
the star of that film is is a man named
will Schwarz who's the editor of the New
York Times Crossroad puzzle and uh we we
pitched our idea to him I just I called
the New York Times and left him a
voicemail and he called me back that was
the beginning of that film um but I told
him what we had in mind and he said to
me he said well he said this sounds
really
fun
um and I I just want to tell you there's
a team that's three or four years into
making this very same sort of project
but they're not done yet and I I don't
know haven't heard from them in a while
I I don't know where they are on this he
said so the the one thing I would ask
you is if you're going to make this
movie I'd like it to be done in a
year because then you know it's not too
much work on him and we'll create some
momentum and we won't stop till we
finish it a year after we had that
conversation we were together at
Sundance with the film and and that's
really important when I hear that a film
is six or seven or eight years in the
making unless it's hoop dreams or Ken
Burns is the Civil War or something like
an epic film Sherman's march sure if
it's something that's just a giant film
that needs all that time great more
power to you most films are not like
that
and once you lose that momentum it's
really hard to get it back um it's like
going on a road trip and stopping every
10 miles I mean eventually you're just
going to turn around and go back um I
just um I was just uh did a program with
Sundance um um where a bunch of
filmmakers traveled to China and um um
met other Chinese filmmakers and we
spent a week together it was really
wonderful and I was really surprised to
hear that Joe beanie who's uh he's verer
herzog's editor they've done 20 films
together Joe told me that that verer is
the fastest filmmaker he knows I mean
they cut movies in like six weeks maybe
eight weeks sometimes a little longer
but I mean they're fast and verer is not
interested in spending two years in the
edit room you know Joe's an amazing
editor verer is an amazing Storyteller
they get together they bang it out they
move on and I I think that
that's you
know that's an important yeah that's
that's a very important ingredient if
you want to be productive and you want
to make a lot of these kinds of movies
well aside from money what do you think
it is that people ham and ha is it is it
fear of getting something out there
because it's not
perfect you mean like sort of what keeps
people from taking that leap and yeah
and and doing it so fast I mean again
aside from money which is a huge Factor
so let's say money's not a problem or
they're doing it themselves what is it
that keeps people kind of tied to it and
and just not releasing it yeah I mean I
think once people start making their
film their first film um
you know you got to pay the bills you
gota you got to buy the groceries you
have to sort of support yourself while
you're doing it which is challenging but
I think a bigger hurdle is
fear I you know I think that people are
afraid that what they're doing is not
good
enough um and here's the here's the
Dirty Little Secret every
filmmaker is deep down very afraid on
open
night maybe it worked maybe it didn't
you're so close to the material by then
that it's possible to know if it worked
or not
um I'm constantly amazed at how many
classic films I've heard about where
opening night everyone thought the movie
was a bomb Jaws is a very good example
Richard
dfus was quoted in several articles
about God this movie took forever to
make and this young director and I don't
know what we have here you know and he
stormed out of the theater opening night
saying he did it he did it it it's it's
it's a miracle this movie is
unbelievable
and I'm sure that two hours earlier step
Spielberg was sitting there
wondering if he was going to have a
career or not you know it's the these
these things are hard to make it's hard
to make it's hard to make a movie and
it's hard to tell a good story so put
those two together and you know welcome
to show business that's really what this
is about um and again I feel like if
you're surrounded by people you trust
and you have a good team a good small
team you should make your film as well
as you can as quickly as you can have a
couple of screenings with six or eight
people who come over and give you honest
feedback address those notes and get it
out there you know
um um it's it's uh it's one of those
things where you only get good at it if
you practice at it and you just have to
keep you just have to keep practicing um
I think that's how you get
good now Ted let's come back um to your
first directing job you know believe
you've said that your first directing
job was was all or nothing if it didn't
go well you would have been out of a job
and on the street and you could have
played it safe you could you could have
declined the directing job or the
directing assignment but you decided to
risk it all so knowing what was at stake
how how how did you approach the work
well what happened was that I was the
for in when I when I was 23 I was a
story editor of the series General
Motors theater and the man who produced
it Sydney Newman um he um said to me one
day you know Ted because I was doing a
lot of rewriting it was a great training
because people directors I'm 10 minutes
short I need two scenes right I'd write
two scenes and and then um but after
about a year of this um the producer
Sydney new came and said to me you know
Ted you're a pretty good writer not a
great writer but a pretty good writer
but I know but I know one thing you
really would be good great at and I said
what's that he said you'd be a great
director now why he said this I never
asked him why he said this he said
here's what I'm going to do I'd like you
to do you're going to do one show for me
live television drama if I like it I'll
give you a Year's contract if I don't
like it you're out in the street you
can't come back to this
job um and I said I'll risk it he said
if you don't want to risk it you can you
can stay on because you're doing a great
job it's a story editor I said no no no
I want to be a director I'll risk
it and um so he he he allowed me to
direct and of course I worked my butt
off getting get every shot cuz it had to
do it live it was nothing like I tell
you a funny story about directing life
on the series The theme music was
Charlie chaplain's smile
smile smile when your heart is breaking
that was our theme music right of course
as just before the music on the
assistant saying 10 9 and my stomach
start cheing it's going all across
Canada 7 6 and you're ready ready ready
the Music Ready on camera
2 hit the music Fade up on camera 2
super the titles kill them for God's
sake cut to three go on move a little
closer a little closer please take take
one and you it's right you were
conducting the whole show non-stop right
and your stomach's going in adrenaline's
up to here dissolve 20 years later I'm
in a lovely dining room a restaurant
rather with a lovely woman and we're
drinking wine and I was very Mantic and
my stomach starts to turn
oh stop it and it it keeps turning what
do I hear over the loudspeakers of the
restaurant smile when your heart is
breaking
smile to this day I'm like pof's dog I
hear that music my stomach start to CH I
did it for two years anyway he allowed
me to direct um and he was a great a
greatest Mentor for me and I think every
person who wants to start don't be a
director you need someone to Mentor you
and and but what what what made you take
that leap you know knowing that you
could be out of a job no knowing that
you could lose the the safety and the
security you still decided you know what
I I want to do this what where did that
come from well I wanted to be a director
and here I was being given a chance to
be a director how many offers would you
get of that kind in your whole life I
was just I'll let you direct so I real I
just had to grab it I I'm not interested
in a job I was interested in being a
director so you had to take it it was an
opportunity that was being offered to
you it would be it would be silly to
refuse it do you remember the moment
when film making was no longer a dream
and it had actually become a reality for
you do you remember do you remember that
realization or I've had several stages
of realizing that it's still happening
uh sometimes I wake up in the middle of
the night and I'm like wow I'm being
paid to make
movies that's good that's that's a good
thing um but honestly that that one
click never really there was never
really one click
of the dream is now a reality um and I
think it really has to do with the fact
that I guess I've always known
subconsciously that it's all about just
making stuff it's all about just making
art and you can do that whether or not
someone's paying you to do it uh you can
it's just something that you do and I've
always done it so in a weird way this
has been going on since Mark and I were
kids um we're just happen to be doing it
at Studios and at HBO right now it
sounds like too it goes back to what you
said there's no set path yeah there's no
set path yeah and it it almost seems
like it is it some way a curse to kind
of say okay yeah I've made it and
because in in Hollywood whether it's
whatever job it is whether you're makeup
artist whatever you're only kind of as
good as your last job yeah I don't feel
like I've made it at all and I don't I
don't know if anybody feels like they've
made it because you could easily never
do another movie again um no one will
guarantee you a movie even if you have a
three picture deal with a
studio they're not necessarily going to
make it they're just going to look at it
you know um so I
think you know it it all just comes down
to
you just have to make your stuff and and
believe in yourself and and
um and keep doing it you know at at any
level whether it's a $10 million Studio
Movie or a $40,000 Kickstarter
project before they invest thousands of
dollars in this project and years years
of their time what would you want them
to
know
well I would want them to to know that
no one's going to come and hand them a
pile of cash at the end of the process
and say thank you very much that's so
wonderful that you did this and you know
we're all really happy and here's your
money back and here is a wonderful
audience for you like that's number one
you know
and take advantage of the tools that are
available to expand the storytelling
process that are now to really think
about you know to think more expansively
in terms of how audiences engage with
story and to think that potentially
there's a win-win in terms of having
your audience engage with your story
throughout the process with you and what
that can result in in terms of the
audience o owning that process with you
and how that will benefit you as a
filmmaker
and I think it's important you know as
much as possible for filmmakers to get
Beyond this notion that you know and i'
been I've suffered from this notion many
times myself being a director and
especially coming out of the very strong
Resurgence of the aour theory in the 80s
with Scorsese and Le Etc um you
know that while there is a role of the
director in terms of knowing you know
what the is about and being a guiding
principle and having the vision for the
project you know I think it's equally
important for directors to be open to
collaboration and ideas they just have
to be strong enough and talented enough
to filter and make sure that those
ideas fit within their vision and to not
just think that your only collaborators
are your crew and I think the smart
smart directors do collaborate with
their crew but now what is new is that
there's potential to collaborate with
your audience and that often times you
can get
amazing content and ideas from your
audience as much as from your crew
collaborators like even bombit a lot of
that was crowdsourced like I would say
70% of the music of vomit was
crowdsourced you know and not and we did
it in a more primitive fashion because
the the internet tools weren't really
available for it at the time but we did
it on a basis of just calling out to
people and putting calls out to the
internet Etc in a very rudimentary
fashion because this was like remember
this is 2007 so it's like six years ago
now and um it's back when Myspace was
was the thing and Facebook barely
existed so you know um those are
centuries in in the digital landscape
and um so that's what I would say is to
be you know yeah I don't know where that
fell in the 1 two 3 4 but yeah I guess
it would be to collaborate with your
audience as much as your crew Hunter do
you have a day job outside of film
making I actually do not have a day job
and it's taken me a while to get to this
point where I think for the last two and
a half three years I've not had a day
job but I think about day jobs sometimes
I definitely have those moments where
I'm like well maybe I'll go back and dip
in and take some easy cash for a little
while but uh no at this point I don't at
what uh moments do you entertain that
idea
uh it depends I mean it's definitely
moments of frustration when you know you
you work very hard to raise a bunch of
money for Walter for example and uh you
know we we did a crowdfunding campaign
we raised $25,000 and and we spent it
all very fast you know it's basically
accounted for but it was sort of our
strategy with how we're going to release
this film and once you put that money
back out there into the system uh you
definitely have these moments where
you're like gosh it's just too easy to
spend this money and you know we're
we're you know looking at how long it'll
take for the money to start coming back
it's a calculated sort of gamble that
that that we face but you have these
moments where you go through the process
and you see what the industry is really
like and you see how much competition is
out there and how much content is out
there and you're like hm is it really
worth all this energy that we're not
only that we're contributing but now
that others through crowd you know
crowdfunding and and you know a fan base
is supporting to really you know keep
keep after it you know for what what you
get in return so you know you have those
moments that just creep up on you and
then something inevitably happens where
you calm down and you know you something
something comes your way and all of a
sudden you're like gosh you sit down a
lot of times it's sitting down and
seeing an audience watch your film and
feeling it really have the effect that
it's supposed to or you get this
wonderful email or conversation that you
have with somebody and it sort of turns
you back around and makes you realize
it's like this is for whatever reason
this is what what I was put on this this
Earth to do and I got to keep making
these
films so you have now five films under
your belt um at what point of those five
films were you able to walk away from a
day
job so I have five films I've directed
and um there's been another one I've
produced with Mike Dion called reveal of
the path and it was about the time that
um Mike and I came together on ride the
that I was I was actually thinking I was
done for sure and I was working a day
job and or I was uh getting ready to
work a day job I was kind of Shifting
things up and so I I shot this film with
Mike uh Ride The Divide and I was like
okay this will maybe be my last H ra you
know get out there this was number three
number two was a total bomb and I was
like I'll go shoot this enjoy this
moment and then go work and you know
work the agency life and and see where
it takes me but I remember stepping into
that agency life and that kind of put
one foot in and kept one foot out and I
was like I really don't want to work
full-time so I set up a nice little
structure where I was essentially
working full-time but I was contract
position um and it it still that time
that where I figured you know this is
probably going to be the way it goes but
over time as Ride The Divide came out
and was released you know we saw quite a
bit of success with that film and um
that was about the time where I think I
felt that you know I got to just get out
there again and and give it another go
um that was probably it really wasn't
until we saw that film uh take off that
I had that feeling that I could I could
do this full-time but I realized that if
I do it full- time I have to do it
full-time and more than full-time you
know we're filmmakers we're working
every hour we can trying to to get this
this uh content made looking good and
then ultimately distributed and and and
marketed so you know you still have to
check in every once in a while and go
okay I'm breathing there's actual money
coming in from the titles that I made in
the past you know we're figuring out a
system to do this but it's it's not easy
it's not easy money that's for sure and
uh it's usually just enough to kind of
get by and you're kind of finding all
the ways you can to to continue
shortcutting so fortunately it took that
one one title that ride the divide that
kind of gave gave us you know gave me
enough sort of
um confidence in myself but also you
know a little bit of cash flow um and
then and then you know being smart about
my next few titles and not overspending
and finding ways to make sure they get
to Market and that they you know also
continue to give a little bit of Revenue
stream to to our to my Approach yeah I
find Cash Flow is like instant
confidence yeah so it's true cash is
conf it really is I
sad so what would you advise to another
filmmaker who has probably lived that
40-hour week life as most of us have at
one time and training themselves I know
we talked about it briefly because it
seems like it if I remember correctly
from some videos I watched you were
close to going back before you did
Walter yeah yeah for sure I mean it's
you have to keep questioning you know
why you're doing this is it worth it is
um is are the sacrifices you make um
unfortunately the the corporate world
that you see around you that so many of
your friends are are uh investing in you
know and getting return for you know is
is
is tempting at times just because you
see people living this life where they
get things and they buy things and they
consume you know but that's not
necessarily the right lifestyle for
everybody that's certainly not going to
guarantee happiness it's not going to
you know fulfill you if you're somebody
who needs to be creative and needs to
tell stories and and has these thoughts
that you feel are important for the time
and that's and if you if you ignore
those if you're one of those people and
you're ignoring that and you ultimately
you know dip into into that corporate
system you know it's you know it's not
necessarily going to uh to uh deliver
that happiness so I think I got off
track I'm I'm uh you know trying to
trying to remember the exact question
but ultimately oh no no and I think
that's though it's a great point that
you did talk about because maybe people
do need to kind of be able to buy what
they need to buy and then realize like
okay I'm kind of bored now this is not I
don't know if I want to turn my life
over for this many hours just so I can
buy stuff but uh think the initial
question I had was oh how would you
change or how would you train someone or
not train them but advise them from
making that shift because it's one thing
to like say oh I'm going to cut back I'm
going to cut out cable I'm going to not
go to Starbucks and things like that but
there's some drastic mindset changes I
think you have to make right to it's
it's not just going without the morning
latte I think you have
to trust in things yeah for sure I think
if you really want to make
films you have to realize that you're
going to give a lot to that and you're
going to put a ton of time and probably
have to cut a lot of things out of your
life and at some point um you'll get
lucky and at some point you know you'll
work hard enough that the the return
will will start to come for me it's a
matter of I look at film as a long-term
investment and I think most people look
at it as a short-term investment it's
not your first project it shouldn't you
know you're not likely to have that one
hit wonder and take off and totally uh
have this career that's set that's
extremely unlikely and and it's
something that we should be all dreaming
dreaming about and it will happen to a
few but for for most of us it's going to
be something that we really need to take
a lot of time with and find a way to
have a lifestyle that allows you to keep
producing films for some people that is
the the day job and for me it was at
times and I never discount it it may be
again there may be a point where I say I
need to go back and and work uh a day
job for a little while and just have
that experience and let my my mind rest
from having to always you know
compensate and make it happen so this
idea of a drama should be a 4minute
episode a comedy should be no longer
than a three-minute episode and uh it
needs to have something that gum could
sponsor uh Building stories up from the
demographics to me is just like here's
the keys to the
kingdom now do you want to use any of
them or do you want to act an emulate
an industry that has been
storytellers for going on a Century now
because the people with the money get to
make the decisions and the people who
tell the stories
don't here you are you have everything
all you need is money and figure out
some way to do it that's all you
need to do why are you thinking about
well who could sponsor this cuz you need
money well how could we make it cheaper
so we don't need a sponsor so I can tell
the story I want so I can not have to
meet a three-minute thing because the
people who say don't make it longer than
3 minutes don't make it longer than 5
minutes you know they're looking at the
analytics on YouTube going well when do
we lose the audience when do they fall
off who are you are you trying to create
a viral video cuz now you're wasting
your time no one can create a viral
video if you look at the history of
viral videos something happens it's not
that they're just made and they're put
online and they go viral something
happen someone refers to it something
mentions it there there's a number of
blogs uh uh even things that are in the
news now that happened a month ago now
they're a big viral thing you can't make
it happen so why are you pretending you
can why are you pretending to
be a producer that walks around with my
well here's all my demographics and
here's my business plan and really is
that is that what you're dreaming about
when you were a kid is that what you
wanted to do when you wanted a h you
know what I'd love to tell
stories and make movies and wouldn't
that be great I wish there was some way
I could it up what if I started to
make all my stories based on
demographics and pleasing the
sponsorship and trying to get a company
to say yes why the would you do
that now this is never happen in history
ever we've never been here before why
it up with all the that's
been filmmakers for you know the
Indie thing just go from 87 to now it's
been about put it all on a credit card
get it in a film festival get a
distributor to go now all those art
houses are gone the money is not there
the festival are overwhelmed
with
projects it doesn't work anymore and
it's great that Kevin Smith has a giant
audience he can find his way it's great
that Edward Burns has a giant a he can
find his way the other thing is do you
ever want your own audience how you
going to get that you know what you're
going to have to do start with one
fan and then you're only going to have
50 fans just like everybody else and
you're going to have to work to build
that up if you want to be your own thing
but if you want to be an employee
for the factory that tells you what to
do that you have to fit in all these
certain little things and do all this
then go do it enjoy yourself put on
your suit hold up your business
degree I just want to tell stories if
that's what you want to do here's all
the freedom in the world figure it out
stop acting like everyone else because
you know what everyone else is doing the
same thing they're all trying to figure
out the what what girls say about
what this says and what it's such a
waste of time like you can finally get
around all the why would you
make the part of the process it
doesn't need to be and that's what bugs
the crap out of the web series world
it's just too many people want a picture
on a red carpet with a steping repeat
Banner behind them too many people want
another award another award another a
who gives a about all that stuff
yeah it helps with
marketing so does talking to your
audience every day about your story
guess what they want to hear about they
want to hear you talk about your story
that's more interesting to them not all
of them not everybody care some people
just want to go watch something go away
I don't care who made it I don't care
who those people are it's a great story
don't other people who made this where
did this come from who that's and to
have those people that's really cool to
have to have somebody in England
go I've been going through a really hard
time in my life and I found your show
and and it made me laugh and it made me
forget about my kid who's sick and it
made me forget about being unemployed
I'll take that over award Awards
a reviewer saying good job you know
to have someone say who is not part of
an industry your story affected
me I'll take that Paul I want you to
imagine that you are a coach in a room
full of young Indie filmmakers who are
fed up and they're ready to call it
quits okay and so it's your job to
deliver a halftime speech oh my God to
them that will forever shape these
indelible Minds these their film making
careers and these these young you didn't
ask Gary King this question unstable
minds and I want you to be as animated
and as full of life as you need to be oh
my God so you were Rising these guys up
you want me to win one you want my
Gipper speech there you go Super Bowl
was yesterday oh yeah and Denver lost
that's that was my team but see here you
are
imagine you know there get your head
your asses boys like there you go so you
know I say that you don't remember why
you got into this did you get into this
for the glory did you get did you do
this to make money if you want to if you
get into film making to make money
you're the stupidest ever
because film making is the worst most
inconsistent way to make money you get
into this thing to make movies it is a
privilege to make movies why do we make
movies because we love making movies
that's what quent Tarantino says in a
sets when they things are hard and to
move and stuff around they go what do we
love we love making movies you know
here's something my um I was on on 10
till noon we were uh we ran we had an
actor that was a problem another actor
that couldn't remember their lines we
had we were over budget the DP was uh
way too slow we were going to have ad to
the schedule we didn't know where the
money was going to come from our first D
was all over the map we're going to have
to fire him and replace him mid shoot
and I came moment I was unloading all
this stuff on my ex-wife my wife at the
time my ex-wife now unloading all this
stuff and she goes
enjoy
this I go what do you mean she's like
when's the next time you're going to
have the privilege of having these
problems enjoy this you have a film you
can't get into festivals let's look at
that sentence you have a film you made a
film do something with it make the next
film take what you going to go to the
next one you make movies because you
like making movies if there's any other
reward in it don't do it if you don't
like making films if you're not
compelled to make films don't make films
if you are do that and enjoy doing that
thank goodness for digital technology
and the 5D and iPhones and uh Road mics
and and Final Cut Pro and Final Cut X
and whatever else because you can do
them very anybody can make a film now
it's like owning a typewriter or being a
novelist you want to write novels write
novels published or not you want to make
films stop worrying about the festival
stop worrying about the industry worst
thing ever for art and just make movies
there's your Gipper
speeech